STEVE BAZYL: Hi everyone, and
welcome to this week's Google
Developers Live for
Google Drive.
I'm Steven Bazyl and today I
want to talk to you about a
topic which hasn't affected
everyone who's using the Drive
SDK, but there is a certain
segment of the developer
audience that this is
really important to.
And specifically I want to talk
about a feature that used
to be in the Documents List API
that was removed when we
changed that over to
the Drive API.
And this is the presence of
email addresses in the
permissions feed.
This change was made when we did
the Drive API basically to
protect user privacy.
There are some cases where that
potentially could leak
information to collaborators on
a document such as, I share
a file with you and a
few other people.
I know your email address, but
those other people on the
document may not know
you, they may not
know your email address.
And since they have access to
the file, they can use the API
to read information and we
don't want to leak that
information.
There's also some other
cases where--
in the future we may do things
like allow somebody to share a
doc to Google+ circle.
And that's cases where you may
have people in your circles
who you never knew their email
address in the first place.
And so email as a primary
identifier for the users in
terms of permissions
over the years has
become just less important.
That said, there are some really
important cases where
that information is useful.
And this is particularly
for enterprise cases.
There are a lot of applications
that do auditing,
data loss prevention.
Even if you're just building
a collaboration app and you
happen to have some social
features in your application
and your app uses email
addresses, being able to map
the ACLs and the collaborators
on a document to your users
via email is actually pretty
useful in a lot of
circumstances.
So it's been out of the Drive
SDK for a while, but we've
heard a lot of these different
use cases from developers and
have started to restore some
of those features.
Before anyone gets too happy,
there are going to be some
restrictions when this
is fully rolled out.
There are cases when we will
be able to give you back an
email address for a collaborator
in the API.
And this is actually already
available in the Drive SDK.
So specifically, if the user's
profile, in fact, their Google
profile permits you as a viewer
to see their email
address, the Drive API will
honor that setting and return
back the email address
for that user.
And of course, you can
always see your own
email address as well.
For collaborative apps, project
management, this is
actually a pretty reasonable
setting.
It respects user privacy
while still giving you
some of those features.
And there's another feature I'll
talk a little bit about
more that you can use to close
some of those gaps where if
you already know somebody's
email address but they choose
not to share it, there
actually is a
way to handle that.
We'll talk about that in
just a few minutes.
And there's some other cases
where we can return email
addresses as well.
Not all of these are live in
production, but things like
collaborators within an
organization, a Google Apps
domain, for example.
If the domain administrator
chooses to enable that, we can
share out some details.
Again, that's not something
that's live today, but ability
to return email addresses is
there and it will become more
visible to applications as some
of those policy pieces
are put into place.
An interim piece as well is even
though we can't return
back to the full email address
of user, we will always return
back the domain portion.
So this is not a unique
identifier for the user, but
for cases such as data loss
prevention or you're doing
auditing for a Google Apps
domain, it does give you
information about whether or not
that collaborator is part
of your organization or somebody
who's outside.
And I'll actually
show you this.
I'm going to set you over
to the APIs console.
And I just did a query here for
a document that I shared
out of my account.
And it has two collaborators
on it.
One as myself as the owner.
And we can see here does return
back an email address,
in this case, because
I can obviously
see my email address.
I've taken advantage of Chrome
DevTools to sanitize this, but
my email address is not
all that secret
to begin with anyway.
But then we can see another
collaborator here, which is
just my corporate account
at gooigle.com.
And in this case, because I
haven't set my email address
to be visible by this account,
we don't see an email address.
But we still see that this is
an account that is owned by
google.com and at least
gives me some idea of
who that person is.
And again, you can use this
for auditing, data loss
prevention, and so on.
So there's this ID field.
So one of the things with the
permission IDs is these are
actually stable identifiers that
identify the target of
the permission, not necessarily
that permission itself.
So this ID, this permission ID,
is actually an obfuscated
ID for my google.com account.
And so basically for any
document I'm always going to
appear with that
particular ID.
Likewise, for my personal
account, any time I'm
referencing a permission,
it will always
have that ID as well.
So these are actually stable
identifiers that you can use
and store in your database to
map those to known accounts.
So if you have a bunch of
people, you're building a
collaboration app, as they
connect to Drive, you can
query the about feed or you can
look at a file that you
create and pull off the
permission ID and save that.
So then that way any time that
you're trying to understand
what exactly the ACLs mean,
you can then just look up
those IDs against
your database.
So there's one case that's not
caught by this feature alone,
which is suppose you have a
set of users and you know
their email addresses.
So when they signed up you
collected it, they were happy
to share that with you.
And maybe not all of
those users have
connected your app to Drive.
Or even if they did, you may not
be able to get their email
addresses from that.
There's actually a way that
given a known email address
you can actually look up
that permission ID.
This is, again, not a feature
that is in prod yet, but
should be in the next couple
days to a week or so.
But there's a new API method.
This is Drive dot permissions
dot get ID for email.
And it allows you to take a
known email address and
convert that into one of these
stable permission IDs.
So in this case I just looked
up my corporate account.
Again, I share my email address
pretty widely, so I'm
not hiding here.
But what we got back down here
at the bottom is this ID.
So you can see here it's
1251 blah, blah, blah.
If we go back to the permission
on that file that
was shared to me, we can see the
ID here is that same ID.
So basically this gives you a
one way path to take a user
where you know their email
address, can look up their ID,
and then use that as a way to
augment the information you
get back from our permissions
collection.
If you're thinking about a data
loss prevention product
where you really need to have
these emails, you basically
use this as a way to backfill
information.
So for the email addresses
that you know are trusted
collaborators with your
organization, you can go in a
background process, look up all
these email addresses and
find their IDs and save those.
And if you were to encounter a
document where there was a
user who the domain portion was
outside your organization,
the ID didn't map to anything
that your application knew
about, that would be a flag that
you would raise, and then
you can go and ask the document
owner, who is this
person that you shared with?
Give me more information about
them and then you can take
appropriate actions.
But the tools are there now,
at least mostly there, to
restore a lot of the use cases
that were previously possible
with the Documents List API
while still balancing those
against the need to protect the
privacy of users for those
who choose not to share
their email
addresses with other people.
So hopefully for those that
this has really been a hot
topic for, and there are a
handful of developers that
have been asking for some
improvements here for a long
time, hopefully this will get
you back on track to where you
need to be.
We certainly always welcome
your feedback on these
features and whether
or not these
actually meet your needs.
But we're pretty confident
that this strikes a nice
balance between the needs
for applications and
administrators to understand who
documents are shared with
while still balancing
privacy needs.
So that's all for today.
We'll be back next
week as always.
And if you do have any questions
on this, feel free
to reach out on our Google
Drive Developers
community on Google+.
You can also ask questions on
Stack Overflow as always with
the Google Drive SDK tag.
So that's it for today.
Thank you very much, and we'll
see you next week.